among all the other effects of this war
here in ukraine food is one of them the
reality is that ukraine supplies so much
food to the rest of the world places
like africa and to the middle east and
grains and other crops are sold on a
world market basis and because of the
war much of the food production here is
not going to happen this year two-thirds
of the crops have been planted in this
area in ukraine that's actually pretty
good considering a war is going on right
now but a lot of last year's crop
millions of tons of grain still sitting
in silos can't go out to market and
challenge for all of us how to sell the
grain which will be produced
and
which is in growing now fixing that
problem is not going to be easy experts
say and the reality is there won't be
enough food for all the people demanding
it the worst is is is actually ahead of
us because of the conflict in ukraine
canadians are also going to feel the
effects of this supply shortage not
because there isn't enough wheat and
other grain in canada for the market but
prices are likely to be going up if
access is not a problem
then food affordability is with prices
going up and canada is actually not
immune to this
we're seeing prices going up in canada
as well so what's the solution to all of
this well obviously it's the end of the
war but that's nowhere in sight and the
reality is with so many people in the
world to feed we're normally fed by
ukraine there's going to be a shortfall
that's going to show up especially in
the next few months sean o'shea global
news in eastern ukraine